えーと 今のお話にして質問などもうだいぶ行いましたけど
引き続き時間をいただいたと思いますので
ご質問などありましたらお願いします
あの なんでそのヴィンヤーナパチヤナーマーラとかをお釈迦様の言葉であるんですけど
その逆の言葉はサーリプッタ尊者セットになってるんですか？ まあ記録のところはサーリプッタ尊者が言ってるんですからね
別にあんまり意味がないんです
お釈迦様が言わなかったから
別に言わなかったわけじゃなくてね
質問次第でしたから そういうふうに質問していたんです
ある人が それでヴィンヤーナはどうなるのかと
原因は ったらナマルプにしちゃったんです
でないとキリがないんですよ
そこでもうサイクルにするんです
でないと鶏と卵 卵 それ終わりがないんですよ
で 説明はこの三脚の三脚ではなくて
この何か足の束 2つ立てませんではないかと
それでお互いにこうやって置いておくと
お互いに相互的に立っているではないかと
そんな感じで ナーム ナーム
ルーパを支えてルーパ
ナームを支えているんだと
まあヴィンヤーナはあそこをやるんだからこそ
輪廻転生成り立つんです
とにかく だからアヴィッチャーバッチャなんかサンカーラバッチャ
ヴィンヤーナ始まるでしょ
ヴィンヤーナは先です
見方によって  もっと簡単な質問
専門的な用語を使いこなして
もっと素朴なところでご質問などありましたらお願いします
心は業で変わるという言葉で
心は業で変わる で 業は実は意志
うん  それは欲望が違うんです
ん？ 意志は欲望が違う
似ています だから意志には色がないんです
意志には 欲望といえば別な感情なんですよ
だから意志は水のようなもので
欲望というピンク色を溶けちゃうとピンクになるんです
だから意志自体が確実に善でも悪でもないんです
それに別な感情を付着するんだだからそれによって悪にも善にもなります
例えば 意志と怒りが一緒になっちゃうと
怒りの意志で それも業なんです
悪い心なんですね 欲が入っちゃうと
もう欲の心 悪い心なんですね
では清らかな感情が入ると善の業なんですね
だから業といえば善業
悪業 2つありますから
だから業の業という言葉は一般的に使う
悪業するなよと 善後しなさいよと
専門的に心理学を語る語る場合は意志取る
意志を取るんです 意志はポテンシャルエネルギーで先へ展開させるんです
しかし その意志にあらゆる煩悩が付着する
悪い煩悩が付着すると悪業という悪意志という良い感情が付着すると善業だという善行為という
だからその付着するものと
意志そのものはもう余計に分けてるだけなので
うるさいんですけどね
だから確実に意志意志は煩悩ではないかとか
欲望ではないかと決めちゃうと
本当は困るんですよ だったら意志自体も殺さなくちゃいけないんでしょうに
そうでもない 悟るためにも意志が必要なんですよ
心悟り開くためにも 良いことをするためにも意志が必要なんです
だから意志には色を付いてないんです
ただポテンシャルだけ
やりたいだけ 何がやりたいのかということで
悪いか良いか決めます
最後のところの心の現れ
現れては消えて現れて消える
17年 現れるのはわかるのですが
消えるのは感知できるんですか？ 消えるのはすごく難しいんです
感知するの  現れるのは次々こう
だから現れたらわかるんですよ
消えたらわからないんです
だから世の中みんな我論になっているのはそういうわけなんです
実体あるんだと 魂があるんだと
だって心はあるということしか知らんから
ないということはなかなか知りえませんだから
で 瞑想する場合でも もうずっとこれあのジリジリと推測で発見するんです
推測で たくさんデータ取って取って取って取って
もう嫌になったところで
やっぱりもう消えるものでもあるとわかるんです
で 経験するときはもうほとんど悟りの世界なんです
現れるのはわかりますけど
本当にもう消える瞬間はわからないんです
それはわかると  論理的にはね
大体わからないと言ったってもいいんです
心がもう飽きちゃうんです
そのこのプロセスに いつ物事を観察してもすぐ消えますから
どんどん飽きる気持ちが出てきて
無執着の気持ちが気持ちが出てきて
全部捨ててやるぞと という強烈なエネルギーが出てくるんです
意志なんですけど その意志が出た瞬間で
次の心は何も取らなくなくなることになります
何も取らなく 心は心とも言えないんです
それが涅槃という悟りという瞬間なんです
だからまあ あまり滅はね
この大体推測ですよ 推測と推測でいくんです
その場合の推測は きちんとデータがあって推測するの
家に入ったらもう窓は破れているわ
ドアの鍵は壊れているわ
中に入ってみたら もうタンスやら全部もうあっちこっちもうごちゃごちゃもうもういろんなことをさせているわ
それでお金が見たらお金もないわ
まあ泥棒入ったんでしょってことでしょ
しかし 自分の目で泥棒入るのを見たわけじゃないんです
あまりもデータがありすぎて
やっぱり泥棒が入ったと決める
そういう推測です だから
この感情 先駆的な先見的な推測は
仏教は頑固と反対する
この代わりにたくさん経験的なデータを取って
そこからはいくらかのできる推測はもう認めます
だから ただドアが開けたところで鍵かけてなかったと
それだけで決めるなよと
泥棒が入ったんだと 自分が鍵かけ忘れることもありますからね
それで鍵は開けているわ
行ったら窓も壊れているわ
いろんなものを品物を入れている引き出し
タンスは全部もう外へ出しているわ
もう調べたらあれもないわ
これもないわ それだったらもう空き巣に入ったと思った方がいいでしょ
そういう推測なんです
だから 死ぬということは
それぐらいの推測 すごい瞑想すると
もう心はやむを得ず そんなもんやと決めるんです
それで諦めがついて この諦めが衝動になって
チェータナに意志になって
悟りの心生まれるんです
あ それぐらいでいい感じでございます
これは難しい はいはい
なるほど 日本の仏教ですと
死者に対してん？供養
死者に対して つまり祖先とかですね
四十九日という日に死者に対してこれはどうしますか？そういった死者に対しての供養というのは果たして意味があると思います
うーん それはあの まず考えてみたいのは
我々文化人として死者はね
もう死んだらもう忘れましょうっていうのはね
もうちょっとね あまりにも野蛮的でしょ
だからもう日本だけじゃなくて
どんな人間でも 自分の亡くなった先輩の方々に対しては気持ちは持ってますね
ありがとうございますと
お世話になりましたと
あいつは死んじゃった
親父が死んじゃった もういないという風にはきれいさっぱりするっていうことは
なんかすごい野蛮的なんですね
だから意味があってもなくても
こんなのはね 消えてほしいってわけでもないんです
生きてる人間はもうちょっと感謝を覚えて
恩を知っている人間になった方がいいんじゃないかなと
それは文化的なことで
供養する側の自己満足ということになってしまうものなのか
果たしてそのどちらの思いが本当に死者に通じるのか
今の状況を見ると ほとんど自己満足のためにやってますよ
自分の見栄を張るために
だからそれだったら死んでよかったということになりますね
えらいド派手に葬式できたんだからというね
これはもうあまりよくないんですよ
必ずしも死者に影響を与えるということはあります
仏教でもお釈迦様はそれはありますとはっきり言ってます
供養すれば それはもうはっきり届きますよと
しかし 甘く考えるなよと
私は自分の父親が亡くなったところで
父親のことは悲しくて
かわいくて もうたまらなくて
一生懸命供養しても 確実に父親に行くということは
これはもう宇宙の法則の中ではこう約束はないんだと
それも例えば私の 私の場合は子供はないんだから
自分の弟子たちが何かいいことをしているんだなとわかると
自分がすごく楽しいんですよ
あの連中もなかなかいいことをやっているのではないかとかね
ああ よかったよかった
すごく気分がいいんですよ
それで何となく自分にも自信がつくんです
じゃあ私も頑張らなくちゃと
で 落ち着く それで電話でも何か向こうは何かとんでもないトラブっちゃったなと思っちゃうと
私はガクンと落ち込んじゃうんです
何やってるんですかと
やっぱり私は大人としてそばにいて
いろいろいじれないと
こいつらは本当にまだまだっていう気分というのはなるし
そういうことで心がつなげてるんですよ
これ 結構インパクトあるんです
そこで何かいいことをしたんだという弟子たちが私に報告するのも
自分のことを褒めてほしいというね
で 同時にこれ情報を読んだら
ああ なかなかこいつら頑張ってるなと
ああ よかったよかったと
私も自動的に素直にすごく喜んじゃって
元気になっちゃう その心のその影響がエコーの機能なんです
それ 今も我々にあります
だから これは普遍的な法則で
例えばイラクでアメリカ人軍人がどんどん進んで
もう片っ端から掃討作戦やっても殺しちゃうと
よかったよかった これでテロがなくなったというと
そう思う人々はみんな人殺しの罪に
汚染されています 実際見たこともないのに
そこで日本のボランティアの方々は行って
もう何の政府の何も関係もなく
一生懸命一般の人々と苦労して苦労して
なんとかなんとか井戸を掘ってあげたり
電線引いてあげたりして苦労して話を聞くと
また楽しいでしょ 昨日もテレビで見たんですけど
アフガンで活動しているお医者さん一人の話
で テレビに出て まあだから援助でもしてくださいという話で
そのお話を聞いていると
なかなかやるんでしょうと
私も楽しいんですよ 聞いていると
あれほど激しいところで
苦労もせず 苦労も気にせず
よく頑張っているんだと
だからそうやって心は影響を受けるんです
悪い影響も良い影響ももろに受ける
それが罪にもなるし 善にもなる
で 私はもう何人かに批判もされましたけど
もう頑固とこの戦いやら自衛隊派遣やら
そういうものにはものすごくむちゃくちゃ悪く言うんです
もう関係はないといえば関係ないんですけど
なぜかというと どなたでもね
うかつにあ それはしょうがないもうって思っちゃうと
罪に汚染されているんですよ
誰かさんの言い訳やと
アメリカと日本の関係だからしょうがないやと
それは関係はしょうがないと私もよく知ってますけど
だからって人殺しは罪なんです
だから 心はそういう影響あるんだから
私はもういつでも何かケチをつけちゃって
もう自分の仕事するんですよ
自分の話を聞く人々は
やっぱり罪を犯してほしくない
無意識的にでも そういう
その普遍的な働きが回向にも作用しているんです
そこで亡くなった父親が人間の世界をに対して興味を持っている
もう出て行った世界について興味を持っている場合は
これで子供たちが一生懸命回向していると
そうすると向こうの心から喜びが生まれるんです
それが供養なんです だからって何をしたっても善行にはなりませんよ
ただ すごいかっこつけてお数を持って式台を守って演劇やっても
舞台劇場みたいに 大体そんな私は見てたから
あれはただの歌舞伎と大した変わりがないんだと
みんなドラマやってるんです
それドラマやったって
もうあんまり善行やと思えません
見栄張ってますからね
だから本当にお釈迦様が言うのは
自分が亡くなった親のことをよく考えて善行をせなさいと
例えば親父が亡くなったんだから
これから私はこういういいことをするんだぞと
これからはもう全然人に対して怒りもしませんよとかね
みんなに優しくしてやるぞとかね
そういうことを親父のことを思い浮かべて思い出してやり続けるならば
これはこの上のない供養なんです
だから意味もわからん
意味も不明な また誰かさんが書いた変なオッケーをあげたんだからといって供養になるかどうか
私は宗派違うんだから
これは疑問に思いますけどね
縁起経をあげたって どうしても供養したければ
お釈迦様が確実に教えた慈悲経とかね
そういうものをあげた方がいいんです
慈悲経なんかあげたりすると
そちらになるのはおなりに対する道徳なんですよ
生きとし生けるものは幸せで幸福でありますようにと
そうすると自分の心が清らかになるんですね
それがもう本当に力になって
亡くなった方々には入ります
でも入る場合も 亡くなった方々も受ける準備しておかないと
だから 死んだ方々はみんな供養を受けるわけじゃないんです
だったらやめてもいいんじゃないかと気持ちになるでしょ
欲張りだから こちらも
それは良くない それは自分のすごい悪い心なんです
汚い心なんです 実際は自分の両親が亡くなってどこにいるかやっぱりわからない
まあとにかく供養するんだと
受けても受けなくても
供養することで自分が善行為するんだだから
自分のためには確実になっている
だからもう親戚に行っても行かなくても
それを気にしないで良いことをしなさいという結論になっています
そこでジャームソーニというバラモン人が
バラモン人だからかなり供養をやるんですよ
あまり派手に すごい金持ちの人で
派手に供養をやるんです
ある日疲れたでしょうね
疲れてお釈迦さんに聞くんです
お釈迦さん 我々バラモン人が最近の人々はね
しょっちゅう供養をやっていますけど
本当にこれ親父に行くんでしょうかねと
言ったら お釈迦さんは場合によって
場合によってと それ何なのかと
そしたらお釈迦様 だって受けられる状況にいるならば受けられますよと
受けられない状況にいるところはどうしようもないんだと
だったらその供養はどうなるんでしょうかね
言ったら別な親戚に行くんだよと
もしその親戚行かなかったら？だったら別の親戚に行くんだよ
では お釈迦様はその親戚も受けなかったらどうします？お釈迦様はけど
あのね この輪廻の中でどれほど親戚あることあんた知ってるんですかと
輪廻というのは無限だよと
過去は だからあなた思うほどじゃないんだよと
ものすごいいるんだよ
自分の親戚たちが個人の
供養を待っていて だからしょっちゅうやりなさいよと
親父だけに供養すると言っちゃうと
親父がダメだったらそれで受けなくなっちゃうんです
だからテーラワーダでは私の親父に供養するというふうな文章は言わないんです
すべての親族に供養しますと
もう無限にスケールが広げて供養するんです
実際はもう７日前に亡くなったお母さん
お父さんかもしれませんよ
それでお母さんと他のその他のすべての親戚に供養しますという文章でやるんです
真面目にやってますよ
なぜかというと 自分が与えた功徳が誰かが受けて幸福になってほしいという気持ちがあるんだから
一応正しいやり方 そういうやり方なんです